in a cemetery in east java
they gather these are the offenders
indonesia's covid rule breakers
their punishment
to clean the graves of the newly dead
locals killed by coronavirus
19 regulations
um
east java has indonesia's highest
coronavirus
death toll
so here in grecic authorities are making
a stand
patrols stop people without face masks
excuses don't work pay the fine
or it's covered community service
jacket declaring violator marks the
offender out
then they join the rest of the guilty
loudspeakers ensuring their neighbors
know what they've done
as they head to the cemetery
the punishments are varied and
imaginative
in jakarta people have to get into
coffins
back in grecic others are told to lie in
an ambulance
some tell us it's hot others it's scary
but it works
in the last three weeks more than a
million people violated
covet 19 regulations across east java
alone
but authorities say the public
punishments encourage
more to follow the rules a potential
lifeline
in a country with the highest
coronavirus death toll
in southeast asia siobhan robbins sky
news